Dave Portnoy the founder of barstool
sports el Presidente
he was watching last night's debate had
one of the best Twitter feeds on the
Internet he joins us tonight so Dave you
are a student of human nature you watch
what happened with Bloomberg last night
you're not a Bloomberg hater or anything
but tell me your reaction to it yeah no
I I really didn't have any opinion about
Bloomberg I was actually watching
college basketball it was a three
overtime game I was and flip the channel
to debate right when Bloomberg was
getting crucified the only thing I knew
him was when he tried to get rid of big
drinks big coats that all I knew about
him but this was like watching Game of
Thrones somebody get absolutely executed
right in front of your eyes and by the
way if every debate was like that I
would tune in for every debate that was
better than anything like you see on you
know HBO or anything like that I have no
idea what this guy was doing for a
billionaire somebody you would think is
smart he looked totally caught off guard
by everything they were saying about him
like some people don't like me not many
some but I know if I'm in a debate with
somebody who doesn't like me I can
pretty much read off their scorecard
what they're gonna do their greatest
hits he look totally confused oh I
didn't know people gonna bring this up
in a debate it was stunning and fun to
watch so if you're Bloomberg how would
you respond how should he have responded
to those attacks do you think once he
hesitated and once he panicked and once
he was going down the rabbit hole if I
were him I would just walked offstage I
said you know that with it I got
billions of dollars I don't need this in
my life because there's no coming back I
mean there is no coming back somebody
like me he was pretty neutral on him now
thinks he's a village idiot I mean
there's no way after respondents be
honest the rest of the debate he was
okay but once you get absolutely savage
like that and you have no comeback and
there dance around just punching you
like a pinata it's done it's game over
there's nothing he can buy there's no
amount of money that can come back from
that you should just said you know what
I made a mistake I'm out of here and he
should have whoever as his vices are I
mean they should be brought out how do
you how do you not tell him you got to
get those questions it's obvious it was
nuts so he's not bloomer stop Mary but
he is a long time
girlfriend who's lived with I think for
at least 10 years he's going home to her
what does she say to him do you think
you know she's probably got a pretty
good gig I mean he's got good zillions
of dollars so maybe you know it wasn't
that bad you give him it wasn't that I
mean what else can you say if he has any
brains he knows his bat he had me so
confused I'm very Pro money I like
making money I want to get good zillion
dollars I want all the money he has he
made me think maybe you're not so smart
me you don't have to be smart to make
money because how can this idiot be up
here so he almost like had me in a mind
trap but if you're the girlfriend you
just got to play along you make him a
grilled cheese put some potato chips in
the middle tap him on the back and say
it wasn't that bad I mean what else can
you do what else can you do so even
Michael Bloomberg can get rich I think
you just exposed the central problem of
the American economy which is it's not
that hard to become a zillionaire that
was like advise Bernie Sanders that
maybe my whole campaign hey it's just
raw luck if this [ __ ] has billions then
it should all be spread new clean I do
not agree with that but if you're trying
to take my my big hey out Bloomberg get
it look at this idiot that honestly is
what I felt like is like whoa how's this
guy so rich what a [ __ ]
so good the great Dave Portnoy excellent
to see you Congrats on the company by
the way well
thank you